so uh let's let's now give an example
right we we spoke in the last segment
about this leaked memo thanks to mother
jones we learned about this memo in
which the kremlin is directing russian
media outlets to use segments of tucker
carlson's program because it's
absolutely great for them in their goal
of justifying the russian invasion of
ukraine so now russian state media is
being directed by the kremlin use clips
of tucker carlson they're doing it they
love it okay
here is a new
sequence of clips from tucker carlson's
program i believe this was friday night
going going into the weekend
um tucker carlson jumped right into
these now debunked claims about
so-called uh bio labs in ukraine
and tucker goes right into joe biden is
funding secret bio labs in ukraine and
conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens let's take a look at
the clip last night we told you that the
biodemonstration is funding a number of
secretive bio labs in ukraine labs that
are conducting experiments on highly
dangerous pathogens now that's not a
story as we told you we wanted to do in
fact we didn't think it could be true
it's so over the top and bizarre in any
case the administration had repeatedly
and very aggressively denied that they
were doing anything like this
and then they attacked anyone who asked
questions about it as a tool of russia
we foolishly assume that in this one
instance they might be telling the truth
so
these claims have been widely pushed by
russian media this is this is like a
straight up
russian propaganda story tulsi gabbard
fell for it we're going to talk about
that later in the show
and it has really worked to
shift the narrative onto something that
is not only a distraction it's also
untrue the united states has
worked with
ukrainian labs and labs in all different
parts of europe and around the world
on all sorts of public health research
which sometimes includes
research on pathogens this is not like
really a big deal there's no conspiracy
it's not hidden it's not unusual it's
not secret the new york times has a good
article on this and the right is just
loving spreading this propaganda
there are biological laboratories in
ukraine they've been around nearly 20
years and much like the u.s has done to
all sorts of institutions around the
world the us has provided some funding
to a number of institutions with the
goal of researching pathogens
preventing the production of biological
weapons or knowing how to respond to a
potential bioweapons attack etc
the story that tucker carlson and the
fox news
milieu and others
have misleadingly uh uh pushed
is
based on some remarks from american
officials that were misinterpreted as
proof that the labs are producing
biological weapons or conducting
research on biological weapons there is
no proof of that and the u.s is
certainly not running these labs anyway
so later in the segment tucker carlson
he probably knows that the claim that he
made is is pretty flimsy
he moves the goal posts
and he ends his monologue sort of
implying
that even if it's just research on
pathogens it's by its nature suspicious
it started about being you know bio
weapons and weaponized all this stuff so
then it's just well even if they're just
researching deadly pathogens that's
suspicious too in fact the us embassy in
kiev has acknowledged joint american and
ukrainian research on other passage
pathogens such as hemorrhagic fever
virus
apparently there's a lot of this going
on in ukraine funded by the united
states did you know that why ukraine we
don't know we can only guess now by
their own stories about the covet
pathogen research labs remember the
whole wuhan lab story that's where it
came from it was developed there covet
escaped or was released or whatever
by their own claims about that
you would think they would realize well
research into pathogens isn't suspicious
in and of itself and it's certainly not
unique to ukraine
they're the ones who have been saying
it's going on in wuhan
uh and then the sort of like cherry on
top with this tucker story is he blink
brings on glenn greenwald
who
kind of like a
former leftist kind of now just a
reactionary um tucker brings on glenn
greenwald as an expert on detecting
deception i mean i okay i don't know
about that and glenn greenwald echoes
tucker carlson's completely distorted
claims about the bio labs take a look
last question maybe you don't know the
answer but why ukraine you know of all
the countries you would conduct this
kind of research in you would pick one
with like a solid medical infrastructure
you'd pick germany or israel or some
place with you know first-class
scientific research going on you would
not pick ukraine why ukraine
unless you viewed russia as your primary
threat as unless you wanted to be
provocative toward the russians unless
you wanted to
be in ukraine developing all sorts of
weapons as we clearly have been we've
been flooding that country with lethal
arms for five or six years so clearly
there's an intention for the united
states to be heavily involved in ukraine
the russians say their motive is to be
threatening and provocative the united
states denies that but they have their
tentacles in ukraine and have for many
years all the time which is a critical
part of the narrative that has been
lacking that's right it's fair to ask
what have they been doing in your
opinion why are all their kids working
for ukrainian companies what is going on
here
um glenn greenwald i appreciate you
coming on tonight thank you
thanks tucker now of course tucker asks
why ukraine and the reality is
they're only talking about ukraine and
this is actual russian propaganda maria
zakharova spokeswoman for russia's
ministry of foreign affairs i mean quite
literally a russian propagandist
said on march 8th
ukraine has been concealing traces of a
military biological program supported by
usdod
the truth is there are 59 labs around
the world that handle deadly pathogens
as of a few months ago
and the united states you the u.s as
part of a consortium which we'll later
talk about um sometimes funds research
that goes on at these labs there's
nothing unique or special about what's
going on in ukraine and remember that a
bio lab and a bio weapons lab are two
very different things and the story
muddles the two
makes debunked claims about operational
agreements and funding and all these
different things and in the end it's all
meant to run interference for putin and
it doesn't change the fact that putin
chose to invade ukraine uh we'll have
some of these clips if you've just been
listening on our instagram at david
pakman show we'll take a quick break and
be right back
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video